et pour en parler nous sommes avec axel
perdre son secrétaire général cgt
cheminots de tra bonsoir axel person
merci d'être avec nous vous avez
manifesté aujourd'hui plusieurs de mes
camarades était mannequin manifestation
aujourd'hui à titre personnel j'ai pas
pu y aller mais oui avec plusieurs de
mes camarades qui étaient en
manifestation aujourd'hui devant
l'assemblée nationale oui alors à la
mobilisation attendue après on savait
que ça n'allait pas être la même ampleur
que les manifestations précédentes
devaient pas être appelé par les mêmes
organisations par qui n'ont pas
forcément la même force de frappe mais
il y avait quand même quelques milliers
de personnes de tous tous les avis
qu'ils ont commenté la participation qui
témoigne du fait que même si le projet
aujourd'hui discutée à l'assemblée
nationale l'opposition elle continue à
s'exprimer avec ceux prescrits mais à
nouveau d'ailleurs dans des proportions
sans doute un peu plus importante à
nouveau jeudi qui arrive le jeudi 20 où
nous serons nombreux à être à nouveau en
grève et aux manifestations à nouveau
quoi est justement vous croyez que ça va
peser puisque ce fait des semaines des
mois qu'il ya des mobilisations et eu de
grandes grèves qui ont bloqué la france
qui pour l'instant n'ont pas eu l'effet
escompté
du point de vue des opposants à ce que
désormais vous n'estimez pas que la
bataille se fait au parlement une partie
de certains en tout cas parlementaire
mène la bataille politique dans le
parlement en effet mais après il
faudrait quand même aussi est nuancée
justement ce constat parce que quand on
constate le point de départ du projet
gouvernemental et patronales il ya eu
des inflexions insuffisante au demeurant
qui ont été accordés au fur et à mesure
que la grève s'est étendue et des
concessions quant à accorder à
différentes professions mobilisé y
compris les nôtres donc ça au contraire
ça conforte l'idée que c'est par la
grève qu'on avait à défendre ses
intérêts en revanche en effet dans la
mesure où le texte n'a pas été retirée
oui l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé au
départ n'a pas encore été atteint
partant de ce constat lorsqu'on dit pas
c'est qu'il faut continuer la
mobilisation est en effet on pense pas
que c'est au parlement que ça va se
jouer
c'est même si c'est une étape parmi
d'autres dans la bataille mais que c'est
bien dans les grèves et les
manifestations qu'on pourra obtenir
satisfaction de l'objectif à savoir le
retrait du projet de loi
on vous le dites vous même vous avez
obtenu des concessions vous les
cheminots c'est le cas également
d'autres pros de profession est ce que
vous y croyez vraiment à ce retrait
total de la part du gouvernement
en fait j'y crois dans la mesure
uniquement j'ai dû bien uniquement ça
dépend des travailleurs si les
travailleurs se mobilisent massivement
oui en effet ils n'auront pas le choix
que de le retirer
mais si la mobilisation est insuffisante
bas on ne pourra pas dépasser le constat
qu'on a fait tout à l'heure c'est à dire
des inflexions à certaines catégories et
en plus les inflexions ne sont pas de
nature non plus à calmer la colère y
compris auprès des cheminots parce que
les concessions qui était accordé son
catégorielles à son générationnel elles
concernent souvent des agents ou des
salariés qui sont en poste mais souvent
prive les générations à venir des mêmes
droits
donc même si le gouvernement recule en
partie sur son projet même ça ce n'est
pas suffisant mais en effet il y en a
pas que d'autres choix que de poursuivre
par la grève et il va falloir trouver
des moyens de l'amplifier est de la
maintenir dans la durée
il va revenir sur ses moyens il
n'empêche on l'a dit un le débat a été
lancé officiellement l'assemblée
nationale avec ce nouveau ministre qu'on
a vu sur ces images olivier véran vous
avez trouvé comment son ministre c'est
un peu trop tôt pour
j'ai après on est c'est quelqu'un qui
s'est déjà illustré par le passé parce
qu'il n'est pas de tout à fait anonyme
s'était notamment illustrée par la
volonté notamment je sais pas si les
auditeurs s'en souviennent mais de
s'attaquer notamment référence à la
sécurité sociale
plusieurs fois dans les années qui se
sont écoulées donc il s'inscrit dans la
ligne politique qui est celle du
gouvernement donc partant de là il
n'aura pas beaucoup de différence avec
sa prédécesseure is ses prédécesseurs sa
prédécesseur au ministère et 20 pour
suivre la même politique donc la
question ce n'est pas tant la personne
en réalité s'il te la politique et même
on sait qu'elle sera pas si différente
que ça de l'année ce but ça a pas l'air
de nous choquer justement ce changement
de ministres sur des très gros dossier
mais de la santé les retraites
évidemment mais aussi le coronavirus la
réforme de l'hôpital les urgences on
change de ministre pour aller courir les
municipales qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
oui évidemment pour
pour le personnel hospitalier
dans la mesure où ils sont dans un
secteur qui subit d'une part la crise
sanitaire là qu'ils doivent gérer mais
en plus de ça une obligation
préexistantes qui dure depuis plusieurs
mois qu'il n'a pas trouvé d'issue
favorable en effet le message qui est
envoyé 2
de changer à la tête du ministère pour
aller en effet satisfaire aux exigences
électorales du gouvernement à paris
suite à la crise qui a eu avec benjamin
griveaux peut envoyer le signal comme
quoi les priorités du gouvernement ne
sont pas forcément celles du personnel
mobilisé mais ce que je tenais aussi à
souligner c'est que peu importe en fait
ceux qui sont au gouvernement
ce qui compte ce n'est pas tant les
personne c'est la politique qui est
menée ils sont tous d'accord sur
l'objectif qui est savoir de détruire
l'hôpital public donc que ce soit lui ou
un autre vous justement c'est
l'illustration que quoi qu'il arrive les
décisions sont prises le fait que les
ministres changent les projets restent
oui bien sûr bien sûr mais ça date pas
de ce gouvernement là mais oui en effet
la l'interchangeabilité des personnes
qui dira les différents ministères
témoins avant tout de la continuité de
la politique est menée mais on a eu le
même chose sur le dossier des retraites
puisqu'il y avait un commissaire chez
tous et un secrétaire d'état jean pierre
delevoye qui suit pendant la grève
d'ailleurs même si c'était pas forcément
liés à la grève mais a dû démissionner
ils ont remplacé
ce monsieur par laurent pietrasinski qui
mènent la même politique en réalité donc
ce personnel politique là et
interchangeables et mènera la même
politique donc l'interlocuteur importe
peu en réalité alors venir mois le
gouvernement affirme de son côté qu'il
continue à négocier d'ailleurs la
conférence de financement débute demain
est ce que c'est une chance pour vous
que les syndicats trouvent tout de même
un compromis je vous salue pas un
objectif pour nous en tout cas n'est pas
de trouver un compromis et puisque oui
parce que nous on est on est attaqué
donc le constat qu'on fait c'est quand
on attaque il faut se défendre on
cherche pas vraiment à rechercher de
compromis par la discussion
d'autant plus que les dés sont pipés
puisque le gouvernement l'a dit lui-même
il a fixé le cap de cette soi-disant de
conférence où elle dit que si un accord
qui n'est pas trouvée sachant que il a
exclu d'emblée tout ce qu'il appelle la
hausse du coût du travail c'est à dire
pas d'augmentation des salaires pas
d'augmentation des cotisations
susceptible de financer les caisses de
retraite
partant de là le seul levier sur lequel
il veut jouer ben c'est l'âge du départ
à la retraite
donc s'il n'y a pas d'accord qui est
trouvé il a dit lui-même il réintroduire
aller les mesures qui avaient été
rejetés à savoir l'âge déquilibre fixe à
60 80 qui se décalera au fur et à mesure
du temps aujourd'hui clairement axel a
person comment on en sort le 49-3 à la
motion de censure les amendements on
voit que certains dénoncent plutôt une
obstruction aux débats parlementaires
les grèves dans la rue qui ont encore
une fois n'ont pas donné grand chose
jusqu'à présent est ce qu'on va en
sortir selon vous vous risquez une
déception avec la poursuite de ce projet
non après ces mêmes questions de
déception par on se fait pas sur les
termes moral on est engagé dans une
bataille
donc on utile on a trop on décide
quelles sont les armes qu'on utilise
pour ce pur pour se défendre
et là on sur laquelle est inscrite en
déçu ça voudrait qu'on avait des
illusions sur le gouvernement sait que
son gouvernement est déterminé à
détruire à peu près tous les droits
sociaux qui existent dans ce pays donc
ce n'est pas une déception dans la
mesure n'avait pas d'illusions
oui ça pourrait être un échec mais ceci
étant dit ce qu'on peut constater depuis
que le gouvernement
ce gouvernement-là aux manettes c'est
qu' il n'y a pas une seule journée bon
j'exagère un peu dépassée et un seul
trimestre un seul mois dans lequel il
n'y a pas eu des mobilisations qui
s'exprime de plus en plus forte parce
qu'il ya eu évidemment ce mouvement qui
en cours sur la bataille des retraites
mais il a été précédé par celui des
gilet jaune qui a lui-même été précédé
par celui qui avait mené déjà les
cheminots en 2000
18 on voit qu'aux contrats offerts
mesure que le temps avance que les
oppositions se multiplient et ont
tendance même à se durcir donc on verra
bien jusqu'où ça ira mais on constate au
contraire que ce n'est pas la
résignation qui domine mais au contraire
décodeur qui s'exprime de plus en plus
fort tout l'enjeu pour nous en tant que
militant c'est d'arriver à structurer
ses colères et leur donner une vision
d'ensemble et un programme d'ensemble
pour qu'il puisse se battre tous
ensemble avec le même objectif pour
l'instant on n'y est pas arrivé
entièrement mais on a maintenant nous on
a inventé en tout cas vers cet objectif
merci beaucoup axé la personne d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
merci à vous